So Donald Trump had two events yesterday in
Ohio, big crowds, lots of virus flying around.
And I want to focus in on the second event
here.
Donald Trump did one event at Dayton's airport
and then later drove about an hour north to
some other part of Ohio and did an event later
on in the day.
Donald Trump continues to just lie about coronavirus.
Corona virus has now killed more than 200
and 4000 people in the United States.
It doesn't matter.
Trump insists he's done great.
We're doing great.
And he actually has the audacity to say corona
virus affects virtually nobody.
That's a quote, 204, almost two hundred and
5000 dead Americans.
Trump says it affects virtually nobody knows
the disease.
We didn't know.
Now we know it affects elderly people, elderly
people with heart problems and other problems.
If they have other problems, that's what it
really affects sense in, you know, some say
thousands of people, nobody below the age
of 18.
Nobody.
They have a strong immune system.
Who knows?
Look, can you take your hat off to the young?
Because hell of an immune system, it affects
virtually nobody.
It's an amazing thing.
By the way, open new schools, everybody.
It affects virtually nobody.
Can you imagine imagine having lost family
members to Corona virus and hearing Trump
say it affects virtually nobody.
Two Americans died of Ebola and Donald Trump
called for Barack Obama's resignation.
Two hundred and four thousand Americans have
died of this virus.
And Trump is saying we get an A plus.
He said that the Fox News earlier in the day
yesterday and we are seeing the virus affect
virtually nobody.
You decide whether this is someone who's earned
four more years.
Trump still struggling to just speak English,
still unable to pronounce Ulysses S. Grant
Yodlee, William McKinley and the amazing Ulysses
S. Grant.
That's good.
That's sort of like a packaged section of
speech that Trump is using a lot where he
just lists American historical figures.
The crowd actually seems to like it.
And it's not surprising if you see who.
If you look at who's willing to be crowded
together for hours right now, given what's
going on with the virus, it's not surprising
that some of those same people react positively
and cheer when Trump just names historical
figures.
Trump then encouraging the crowd to report
unsolicited mail in ballots to authorities.
What if you're confused?
I'm confused.
It's unclear what he's actually asking people
to do.
The great state of Ohio.
So get your friends, get your family, get
your neighbors, get your coworkers, get everybody
and get out and vote.
Got to get out of.
And in your state, in Ohio, early voting has
already begun.
And don't wait.
And when you see them cheating on the other
side, say if when when you see them cheating
with those ballots, all of those unsolicited
ballots, those millions of ballots you see,
any time you do report them to the authorities,
the authorities are waiting and watching,
report unsolicited ballots sent to other people
and importantly, to stay with the facts and
to stay with reality.
Ohio isn't sending unsolicited absentee ballots.
What Ohio decided to do is to send out ballot
applications.
If you want an absentee ballot.
You fill out the application and you send
it and then you'll get a ballot.
If you don't, you're not going to get a ballot.
Plain and simple.
Then as part of the victimization tour that
continues, Donald Trump continues to whine
and complain that NBC didn't talk about his
Nobel Prize nomination.
They they instead covered the hurricane that
was ravaging parts of the country.
Take a look.
The big deal for our country.
He said, let's turn on the evening hours.
Let's watch it.
This is going to be a big show tonight.
Get ready.
Then NBC, which is one of the most crooked
one of the worst news.
And I'm talking about normal NBC, not amnesty,
NBC amnesty, NBC is the worst.
But I turned on NBC with Lester Holt, another
beauty.
Let's start with a hurricane and then they
went to something and something else.
And that's a first lady getting a little embarrassing
with 20 minutes into a half hour show.
They haven't mentioned the Nobel Peace Prize.
And then it went through the whole show.
They never imagined that I got nominated for
a second one.
They never mentioned.
Trump actually seems to think that these silly
nominations by right wing politicians, most
recently this right wing politician from Norway,
nominated Trump for a Nobel Peace Prize.
He thinks that's real news when there's a
hurricane ravaging peoples homes and lives
in different parts of the country.
It's the epitome of self-centered ness and
narcissism that has become, unfortunately,
commonplace in American politics.
And then for the second straight election
cycle, Trump is campaigning on all the same
stuff.
He's campaigning on middle income tax cuts.
He's got campaigning on build the wall.
He's president now.
Why can't he do it now?
Take a look.
That's got to see.
It's got to cedar.
And we have a lot of new things, including
additional substantial middle income tax cuts
and other tax cuts and and tremendous regulation
cuts.
And we're finishing up with our military.
You know, we're building space for us.
The wall is going incredibly.
This is part of something we've been covering
for a little while now, which is Trump is
running like he's not the president.
Elect me and I'll do tax cuts.
Elect me and I'll do health care reform.
I'll replace Obamacare.
I'll build the wall.
I'll fix the suburbs.
I'll do whatever, you know, whatever.
He's been president for four years.
Why hasn't he done these things already?
He controlled the House and Senate for the
first two of those years.
He's had the Senate all four years.
We need to reelect him to get him to do anything
that doesn't make sense.
And then in barely concealed racism, Donald
Trump says that if Joe Biden wins, Biden as
well as black Senator Cory Booker are going
to destroy the suburbs.
You know, I ended a regulation that will destroy
suburbia if Biden got in.
They will destroy the suburbia.
We call it suburbia of the world.
And we love it.
I know it well.
Westchester County, the suburban.
Sometimes it's if you say suburban housewife,
you're in deep trouble.
So what you do is you say suburban women.
They love, but you don't want they want security
and they don't want projects being right next
to their house.
Okay.
I'm, by the way, that interesting article,
because twenty nine to 30 percent of these
suburban communities are minorities and that
includes them.
They don't want them.
They want safe communities.
They want great communities.
They don't want to have they don't want to
lose the American dream.
It's very simple.
I got rid of the regulation from Obama.
Biden that was destroying suburbia.
Destroying it.
And I think suburbia has got to wake up because
if they get in, you know, who's a judge is
a judge of the problem.
Corey Booker, Corey Booker.
The crowd doesn't have any idea what Trump
is talking about.
I can assure you it doesn't matter.
They'll still cheer sort of half heartedly.
And one bonus clip from Trump's earlier event
where he was in Dayton, Ohio.
Trump tells just a never ending story.
It's five minutes long.
I'm only going to play 40 seconds for you.
Trump goes on an incoherent unintelligible
story about why steam power is better than
electric power for military ships.
I can't make heads or tails out of this.
But notice how the crowd is silent.
They don't have any idea what this guy's talking
about.
The ad goes a lot.
I got a lot of animals.
I like the admirals.
I want to meet with the catapults, sir.
What would you want to meet with the catapults?
I want to find out why the hell the catapult
is so work.
So I went there and, you know, they did in
this system.
It's electric.
It's all electric.
So it's set of steam, which is simple and
great.
Powerful, good.
And they know how it works for years and years.
They decide to go all electric.
Now, if you take a little glass of water,
take this less water.
You throw it in at the end of that day, bring
somebody in from M.I.T. to help you fix it.
George.
And we're dealing with the ocean and rockets
being shot at the ship and all the rough stuff.
Right.
But it wasn't working.
It went on.
It went on and on from there.
I'm not going to subject you to all of it,
but these events bizarre in every way.
And in particular, I said this yesterday,
kindergarten and first grade teachers, they
don't know how to get the whole class to sit
silently.
Trump has figured out how to do it with a
crowd of a thousand.
He Keagan, get them to just be silent almost.
Still like not moving with these bizarre non
sequitur stories.
And we are going to see many more of these
rallies this week leading up, of course, to
the first presidential debate.
Next Tuesday, I will be streaming live starting
at eight thirty p.m. Eastern Time next Tuesday.
I would love it for you to watch the debate
with me.
We will be live on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook.
That's next week.
In the meantime, more coverage of these wacked
rallies on our Instagram page.
David Pakman show and follow me on Instagram
at David Pakman to see a picture of the beautiful
cake that YouTube sent me for our one million
subscriber milestone.
A gigantic cake.
They sent me a cake that would normally feed
30 people.
Here's a picture of it on my Instagram.
David Pakman.
Quick break.
Back after this.